how I balance work and play well my my
flippant but actually kind of relevant
answer is like work is sober play is not
you know I guess I it's one of the
downsides of being self-employed is you
never have anyone to tell you to stop
working and I love being self-employed
like I love the autonomy of it I like
being able to do what I love but when
friends of mine have nine-to-five jobs
when the weekend rolls around you know
it's five o'clock on a Friday and
they're done for two days and the
liberation that comes with that like I
don't want to have a nine-to-five job
but I do I do envy that freedom or when
they go on vacation and they take two
weeks with nothing to do and just that
you know with no pressure and I do envy
that because I the last vacate last real
vacation I took was 14 years ago you
know I went to Hawaii for five days so I
I don't know I'd I think I need a life
coach to sort of teach me how to have a
life outside of work because even when
I'm not working I'm thinking about work
or if I do try and take some time off
then that old sort of like Calvinist
waspy guilt guilt creeps in and I
started feeling guilty about the fact
that you know I mean I canoe instead of
in my studio
I love drugs but they're so bad for me
that I can't take them I mean in a I I
it does sort of bother me that you know
we can map the human genome and we can
put a man or a person on the moon but we
can't invent recreational drugs that are
good for you you know I just don't that
that you know why can't some scientist
summer I guess there was an alexander
silken he was a drug researcher so he
did sort of invent different i guess
chemical isotopes that were intense
psychedelics that weren't that bad for
you so because I I love drugs I just
can't deal with the hangover and and the
long term sort of like cognitive
impairment I feel the same way about
alcohol no I love to drink and if I
didn't ever get hungover I would drink
every night because you know it it's
just especially living in New York New
York is such an easy city in which to be
a drunk you know because the bars are
open till four you don't drive anywhere
you can walk from place to place meet
tons of interesting people so but
unfortunately I I tend to like alcohol
and drugs a lot more than they like me
I've never made any music under the
influence of drugs or alcohol I tried
and it was terrible like I remember one
night 10 15 years ago I came home and I
was drunk I was like I'm gonna write a
song and see what it's like and you know
to write a song while drunk and it was
just bad so strangely enough for you
know for me like liquor and Android
drugs used used to be a release but not
something I ever used like performing
I've never at least doing my own shows
I've never performed drunk and I've
never been in the studio drunk I envy
people who can do that because I mean
you look at the history of music and
like a lot of phenomenal records have
been made while people are under the
influence I'm just unfortunately I'm not
capable